хлопці Ось що осталось біля мого дому Я
в долгу не остався Ні не останусь оця
їхня
техніка вся
прийшли [__] до нас
ці кадри 27 лютого 2022 року на вулиці
вокзальній у бучій зафільмував 64-річний
пенсіонер Валентин дідковський коло нас
понад сотні одиниць російської
військової техніки спалена вщент как
пришли так і на тот свет ушли отут
БТР був розбитий
бензовоз стояв поперек тому що
водій був загинув
[музика]
взрив був коли і пальне горіло отут все
було по плавленому
адрес цієї вулиці з цілами вбитих мирних
мешканців тоді шокували цілий світ
міжнародна спільнота також дивувалася як
українці змогли вщент розтрощити важку
російську техніку власне до цього доклав
руку і сам пан Валентин тодішній член
тероборони пригадує як гранатометом у
власному гаражі допоміг ЗСУ А коли я їх
побачив я заскочив в гараж приготував
все
по карманам гранати розкидав
дідусь
там була моя позиція
звіти почав діяти Валентин зміг влучити
гранатами у ворожій бензовоз вогонь
перекинувся на іншу техніку АЗС добили
окупантів артилерією ми ще що я відгород
відскочив коли з прицепа зіскочив десь
на метро 3-4 і почав вони гранати кидати
оце ми мене спасло там де я
То ми то вистрілили там такі були
прострели що я
в мене там м'ясо бив залишилося
будинок пана
Валентина у тому бою
нині лише дірки у паркані усе інше
пробитий дах стіни та подвір’я пенсіонер
відновив самотужки із сином звичайно в
кредит зайшли до
Головне що криша над головою а все
остальне воно
потихеньку зробиться А ви знаєте я себе
налаштував на те що допоможе не
[музика]
рік тому на цій вулиці частково або
повністю були потрощені всі будинки на
ділянці довжиною у 2 кілометри більшість
власників домівок на вокзальній почали
відновлення самотужки розповідає сусідка
пана Валентина Галина коштів її
вистачило щоб відремонтувати Лише кілька
стін та батареї нас не було ні одної
батареї нас нічого тут не було в нас оце
вже все вже ми робили все от щас привезе
внук гіпсокартон буде обшивати А
гіпсокартон зараз 400 грн один лист
стоїть ми заплатили 70 тисяч за батарей
бо в нас діти розбирати завали
відновлювати покрівлі та робити локальні
ремонти безкоштовно допомагали і
волонтери вони приїздили на вихідних і
допомагали хто чим міг А на зібранні
онлайн пожертви наймали бригади
спеціалістів для капітальних ремонтних
робіт на вокзальній це робила і досі
продовжує робити команда волонтерів
сміливі відновлювати
на вокзальній наші волонтери були одніми
з перших хто допомагали людям розбирати
завали бо там про відновлення будинків
майже не йшлося мова що окрім
українських волонтерів працює ще багато
іноземців там за минулий рік у нас було
більше 30 іноземців І от зараз у нас є
чат на 70 іноземців які вже цієї весни
цього літа хочуть приїхати до нас
допомагати людям розбирати завали з
наближенням весни почались до нас знову
сипатися запити люди звертаються просять
допомогти на мешканцям Вокзальної
прийшли також іноземні благодійні фонди
які надали гроші місцевій владі Бучі
приміром коштом німецького фонду зараз
відновлюють будинок і подвір'я пані
Тетяни
частину будинку демонтували потому що
воно на відновлення зовсім не підлягало
тому демонтували ось будуть
відбудовувати окремо
укріпили стіни
міняють дах є даже потолки потому что
все попровисало воно Слава Богу гараж
відремонтували Дякуємо велике весь світ
зрозумів що війна відбувається в центрі
Європи і вулиця Вокзальна якраз стала
тим символом де для кожного громадянина
світ Чим більше ми оновлюємося тим
більше ми демонструємо що ми робимо і як
ми робимо який результат бачимо бачать
наші партнери інвестори тим більше в них
бажання і довіра до фінансування
за словами міського голови Бучі на
вулиці вокзальній одночасно ведеться
відбудова 112 найбільш пошкоджених
об'єктів серед них 14 будинків будують з
нуля перед цим відновили дорогу тротуари
та місцеву школу загалом за час окупації
російськими загарбниками рік тому місто
Буча зазнало збитків відруйнувальне
понад 190 мільйонів доларів зокрема
пошкоджено більше двох з половиною тисяч
житлових споруд за даними мерії аби
повністю відновити одну лише вулицю
вокзальну потрібні ще додаткові ресурси
якщо Брати по вулиці тому що кожен
об'єкт має окремий кошторис окрему
експертизу і наразі кожне відкриття
будинку після руйнації Це новий проект
новий кошторис але ми плануємо так що
десь
120-150 млн грн ми впишемося в такий
загальний зведений кошторис це складно
їх ще поки що немає нам важливо
надзвичайно отримувати зараз не лише
Солідарність не лише співчуття і
підтримку підтримку яка дає нам
можливість і перемогти І відбудуватися в
цей час
через що ми безмежно вдячні кожному і
кожній хто приймає участь через нестачу
коштів на відбудову більшість мешканців
Вокзальної змушені були зимувати у
частково розбитих оселях кожен мав змогу
подати заявку на компенсацію збитків від
держави загалом на Київщині таких
звернень нарахували понад 60 тисяч
повідомляють у комітеті Верховної Ради з
питань організації державної влади
міського самоврядування регіонального
розвитку та містобудування його голова
Олена Шуляк розповідає у травні в
Україні вступить в силу ухвалений закон
про грошові компенсації з резервного
фонду держави та заморожених рахунків
російського Збербанку на них зможуть
претендувати лише ті українці кому ще не
до кінця або взагалі не відновили оселі
власники вже відремонтованих будинків
теж отримують відшкодування але уже за
рахунок офіційних репарацій декілька
категорій осіб які перші тому що ми для
передбачили закон першочерговість це
родини військовослужбовців це
багатодітні родини це особи з
інвалідністю і це ті хто зараз вже
демобілізований з лав нашої армії тобто
ці люди автоматично вони будуть
підніматися в черзі вище а всі інші вже
в порядку надходження Не перші кошти в
нас вже були сформовані на рахунках це
17 млрд грн як мешканець вулиці
Вокзальної пан Валентин теж подав заявку
на відшкодування завданих збитків але
каже що покладається насамперед на
власні сили і сподівається що до літа
разом із сином самі добудують хату Ми
українці такі люди Ми не любимо
бардака
Звичайно Це було страшно але Ми
потихеньку
Наша вулиця переходить
до Європи тому що ви самі бачите як воно
все відбудовується рік тому
коли там Валентин і не сподівався
що ця вокза
льна здися із символу руйнації війни на
символ відбудови України бути свідком
цього для пенсіонера велика честь
[музика]